عندما تصبح الأمور صعبة على الأشخاص في
ما يسمى بالمناطق الحمراء في إيطاليا ، يظلوا هادئين
ويستمرون في ارتداء أقنعة الوجه بالطبع ،
فإن مهام الحياة اليومية مثل صنع
البيتزا في المنزل مع الأطفال
تتجدد مما يعني أننا نعيد اكتشاف
الأشياء التي في  تقول
ماريا كريستينا باجي ،
عبر الإنترنت
، إن ابنتها البالغة من العمر تسع سنوات تشيشي ليا
تواصل دروسها التي نعيشها في
هدوء في عائلتنا ، تقول ماريا كريستينا
إننا نستمتع بأطفالنا الذين لم
نرهم أبدًا تقريبًا  بسبب العمل ،
ليس الأمر سهلاً ،
ولكن عندما تنقلب حياة المرء رأسًا
على عقب في يوم خفي غير مرئي ، حتى لو
لم يكن يومًا جيدًا منذ مونيكا موريتي
التي كانت تنشر رحلاتها حول
الشوارع المهجورة إلى حد كبير في بلدتها في
قشتالة ، تذهب إلى السوبر ماركت
يبدو أن الإمداد بالجبن ينفد على ما يرام. كانت
بداية أزمة الفيروس التاجي تثير
الأعصاب وتتذكر في البداية أنها كانت مثل
التواجد في فيلم كارثي عن جرثومة
warfa
قالت لي أن الناس يموتون بعد أكثر من أسبوع
، لكنها استقرت هي وابنتها
على الروتين عندما يكون الطقس لطيفًا.
استمر في تناول الطعام لأنه عندما لا يكون لديك
ما تفعله ، فمن المحتمل أن تكون هناك
آلية تنقر في رأسك
تخبرك أنك في مأزق.
التقليل من
خطورة الموقف الذي أعلنوا أن المناطق الحمراء
ستظل مغلقة لمدة أسبوع آخر على الأقل
د.  ماسيمو جالي هو رئيس وحدة
الأمراض المعدية في مستشفى ميلانو
حيث يعالج العديد من مرضى الفيروس التاجي
، وأخشى
أن نتوقع حالات أخرى في العديدة القادمة على
الأرجح العديد من الحالات الأخرى في
حياتهم في الأسابيع المقبلة من هذا
التفشي  ليس فيلمًا ولكنه
بدأ يبدو وكأنه كارثة
بن ويدمان سي إن إن ميلان
نحن نعمل على علاجات ونحصل
على بعض النتائج الجيدة جدًا كما
تعلمون أنهم يعملون بأسرع ما
يمكن على لقاح للمستقبل ولكن  ماذا
يعني سريعًا هنا إذا كان هذا قبل 10
20 عامًا وربما حتى قبل خمس سنوات
كنا ننظر إلى إطار زمني لسنوات
قبل أن نفكر
بجدية في وجود لقاح متاح
، كرس بيتر هوتيز حياته
لتطوير لقاحات بما في ذلك اللقاح الذي
يستهدف فيروسات كورونا الآن نحن
نضغط هذا الجدول الزمني لأشهر ،
وهناك الآن سباق حول العالم
لتطوير لقاح فعال لمكافحة
ما هو على وشك أن يصبح
بديلًا وبائيًا عالميًا  على الرغم من أن هذا هو أسرع ما ننتقل إليه
من تسلسل
فيروس إلى تجربة ، فإنه لا يزال
غير قابل للتطبيق على الوباء
ما لم ننتظر حقًا حوالي عام
إلى عام ونصف كما ترى حتى لو
بدا اللقاح  واعدًا في المختبر ، كل
ما يهم هو مدى نجاحه في
عموم السكان ، ويتطلب الأمر عدة
خطوات لإثبات أنه أولاً
آمن ثم فعاليته وفي
النهاية كيفية مقارنته بالعلاجات الأخرى.
الكثير من الوقت يتعين علينا إجراء
اختبارات مكثفة من حيث السلامة
والفعالية لإظهار أن
اللقاح يمنع العدوى
وهناك تحد إضافي يجذب
شركات الأدوية لتصنيعه بالفعل
، فقد اتضح أن العديد من
التهديدات الوبائية ليست من مصادر الدخل
الكبيرة  شركات الأدوية الكبيرة
ولكن الأمر أكثر بكثير من مجرد مسألة
جني الأرباح ، لن يكون هذا اللقاح
ضروريًا فقط لمساعدة
الصحة العامة ولكن سيتم استخدامه
لطعن  إضفاء الطابع الاقتصادي على الاقتصاد ، سيتم
استخدامه لتحقيق الاستقرار في الأمن العالمي
، حيث حذر كبار مسؤولي الصحة في الرئيس ترامب ترامب
الأمريكيين من أن فيروس كورونا الذي
ينشر اقتباسه أمر لا مفر
منه ولأول مرة منذ اندلاع الفيروس ،
هناك الآن حالات جديدة
خارج الصين أكثر من داخلها وفقًا لذلك.
إلى منظمة الصحة العالمية
للانضمام إلي الآن لمناقشة د.  إيريكا
شينهوا هي الرئيسة المساعدة
لوحدة مكافحة العدوى في
مستشفى ماساتشوستس العام في بوسطن د.
شكرًا لك على انضمامك إلينا ، يوجد 12
مختبرًا فقط في الولايات المتحدة.  يمكنه اختبار
فيروس كورونا في هذا الوقت ، ما مدى
أهمية المشكلة بشكل جيد ، لذا
أعتقد أنه يحد من
قدرتنا على اختبار المرضى الذين قد يكون لديهم
فيروس كورونا ، لكنني أعلم أن هناك
خطة قائمة لإجراء هذا الاختبار
على نطاق أوسع  متاحًا كما حدث
في الماضي مع فيروس كورونا آخر آخر
فيروس كورونا في عام 2012 في
النهاية يشير إلى أن المعامل كانت
تعمل ، ثم أصبحت هناك
اختبارات تجارية متاحة في النهاية ، لذا حذرت إدارة الغذاء والدواء من
أن بعض المنتجات الطبية
مثل أقنعة الوجه أو العباءات يمكن أن تكون  معرضة
لخطر النقص ، هل ارتداء قناع الوجه
يمنع انتشار فيروس كورونا
إذا بدأ الناس في تخزينهم الآن
لا وربما سأشرح ذلك لأن
هذا هو أحد الأسئلة الأكثر شيوعًا التي
أتلقاها من الزملاء ومن أفراد الأسرة
على حد سواء ، فلماذا نفعل ذلك؟  ضع
أقنعة جراحية على المرضى حتى إذا كنت تعاني من السعال
أو العطس كأنك
قد تصاب بالأنفلونزا في كل مرة تعطس فيها نعش
قطرات من التي تحتوي على هذا الفيروس
جزيئاتنا تخرج من فمك
، ولذا عندما نضع قناعًا جراحيًا على
مريض ، فإننا نمتلك ذلك من
الانتشار إذا كنت بصحة جيدة
وتتجول ، فلا داعي حقًا
لارتداء القناع وأنا
قلق أولاً  إحساس زائف بالأمان
رقم 2 ، سيؤثر في النهاية على
الإمداد ونحن نشعر بالفعل
بتأثير الإمداد في المستشفى
وفي أماكن الرعاية الصحية حيث نحتاج إلى
هذه الأقنعة لكل من
المرضى المرضى وأيضًا لحماية
العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية